We've got Lupita Nyong'o here.
Hello.
It's so good to see you.
It's been a long time
since we've seen Nakia.
Yes.
Can you tell us a little
bit what she's been up to?
You're about to find out.
That's fair.
Well, maybe just catch us up
on what it's like that there.
Like, OK, she went to
the beach or something.
She did go to the beach.
The beach is great.
Yeah.
I mean, it's been a while
since we last saw her.
She's grown and matured.
She's also lost her main love.
So we see how she's
handling that.
Yes.
Now, Nakia is a War Dog.
And I know for a lot of
people, they often assume
that she's a Dora Milaje.
Tell us a little bit about--
- A little about--
A Dora Milaje.
Tell us a little bit of the
difference between War Dogs
and Dora Milaje for people
who are not in the know.
Well, War Dogs are
undercover spies.
So they're training.
Yes, they're trained in
combat and stuff like that.
But their training
is very different.
They go under the radar,
whereas the Dora Milaje are
very much the army of Wakanda.
So they definitely
have to work in tandem.
But she's a little
bit more exposed
to the rest of the world.
And she's like, she's the one
who brings intel to Wakanda
that keeps them on top.
Ooh.
I want to dive in deeper about--
I'm so fascinated
about your experience
as being this War Dog, Nakia.
You know, she spends a lot of
her time away from Wakanda.
But she loves it.
What keeps her going
in her mission?
Wow.
Sorry to break it to you.
I mean, wow.
This is like a class
that I need to pass.
What keeps her going?
I think love of country
and a love of her people.
And she is a very
principled person.
There are certain
things she stands for.
And she really believes in the
power of humanity together.
And I think she brings
that to her work.
I mean, A plus right there.
I mean, you just done passed
the class right there.
Lupita Nyong'o, I know
there's so many people
want to get to talk to you.
We're so excited to see
you back here in the MCU
and taking us through
Wakanda Forever.
So thank you so much.
Have you got anything that you
want to say to the Marvel fans
before we head out?
I'm just so happy to be back.
We love you so much.
Enjoy the night, Lupita.
So good to see you.